The production team for Game of Thrones had
some big shoes to fill when it came time to
cast Brienne of Tarth, and they pretty much
nailed it when they hired Gwendoline Christie
for the part.
But even considering her natural aptitude
for the role, Christie had to put in a lot
of work to make the look perfect.
Here's how the six-foot-three actress and
model got her body into the shape of a committed,
lifelong warrior.
Pre-audition training
Months before Brienne was introduced in season
two of the show, fans of the book series took
to the Internet and pegged Christie as an
ideal actor for the role.
The online support is actually what pushed
her to try out for the role, and in the months
before the audition, she was already hitting
the gym to get herself in fighting shape.
Christie is one of the few performers remaining
in Game of Thrones' sprawling cast who is
actually on record as having read all of the
books, so she knew what kind of physique she'd
need to cultivate if she wanted a chance at
snaring the role.
"I read the books and I really, really wanted
to play the part.
I started kundalini yoga, kickboxing and running,
and completely changed my diet.
I felt I wanted to undergo what was necessary
for the part."
Dance background
When it comes to working out, a background
in athletics goes a long way.
Christie had a great foundation, acknowledging
in an interview with Stylist that "at a time"
she could have pursued a career as a professional
gymnast.
"From the age of 7, I just loved dancing.
I did ballet, tap, and rhythmic gymnastics.
I did lots of dancing and was obsessed with
it.
I lived and breathed it."
"And then I had a back injury when I was 11
and had to stop."
The injury precipitated a change in interests,
which led to a career as an actress.
But that early gymnastics background must
have helped her get her through the gruelling
training for Game of Thrones.
Knight's training
One benefit of getting a high-profile role
on an expensive HBO production is that your
physique is going to get some serious Hollywood
help.
In the early days of training, Christie worked
with trainers Phil Learney and Dalton Wong
to pack on muscle and learn how to use the
extra weight.
She told Games Radar,
"I was given extensive horse-riding lessons,
so that not only was I confident on the horse,
but I could ride."
"My physicality was altered so I was much
heavier in the way I walked, less upright
and a lot more masculine."
That's a lot to go through, but Christie approached
it all with a true warrior's mentality.
"I just dedicated myself to it entirely.
There was no room for failure."
In the end, Christie lost 21 pounds and then
gained back about 14 in muscle, leaving her
dramatically stronger and more fit.
Cold turkey
In the messed-up land of Westeros, a mug of
stiff ale is about the only way to get through
the day.
But it's also a luxury the best knights have
to steer clear of.
"Don't get drunk."
"No, m'lady."
To get into prime shape, Christie decided
to cut alcohol out of her diet completely,
along with other diet changes.
She told Stylist:
"I completely changed my eating habits and
didn't drink for about two months, just in
the service of this part."
That's a big sacrifice, but it definitely
paid off.
Acting the part
You've gotta love Brienne's spirit, but the
books rarely describe her looks in flattering
terms.
"Do you think Lady Stark's going to want a
giant, toe-headed plank following her around
for the rest of her life."
So part of her training for Game of Thrones
involved learning how to look and move in
a more masculine way.
Unlike Brienne, who feels at home in a suit
of armor, Christie is much more feminine,
and she had to strip a lot of that away to
prepare for the Game of Thrones role, saying:
"I used to have really long blonde hair, always
wearing heels, lots of make-up.
I had been someone who was highly feminized
and had chosen to look that way."
But as tough of that transition must have
been, Christie took it all in stride with
her characteristic optimism:
"I love a challenge, and I love defying limitation,
gender stereotypes and people's expectations
of me as an actress."
Real steel
Christie's training didn't stop when the cameras
started rolling.
If anything, it intensified.
According to an interview with Vogue, her
costume armor alone weighs 30 pounds, and
the sword isn't exactly a toy.
Even in fights - like her epic battle with
the Hound in season 4 - Christie has to lug
all that weight around.
In fact, she called that fight sequence "one
of the f****** hardest things I've ever done
in my life."
If that doesn't keep her in shape on its own,
it's definitely a motivator not to let her
physical conditioning slip.
Fan loyalty
For all her hard work, Christie has been rewarded
with worldwide renown and an ever-more-successful
career.
Former US President Barack Obama is on record
as a fan of the show who's flexed his authority
to find out what's going to happen to Brienne's
character between seasons.
And in the celebrity world, pop singer Madonna
brought Christie specifically on stage to
compliment her in front of a crowd.
For being a hard-working performer who put
in the extra effort to bring a beloved, inspiring
character to life, Christie deserves the admiration.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!